und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka orden
abend wenn ein präsident einen anderen
als killer bezeichnet und der wiederum
das andere land als unfreundlichen staat
einstuft und beide seiten schließlich
sogar ihre botschafter ab 10
beziehungsweise rauswerfen dann ist die
diplomatie auf einem tiefpunkt
angekommen in einer eiszeit
von daher war es schon bemerkenswert
dass sich joe biden und wladimir putin
heute überhaupt trafen gipfeltreffen
wurde das wohlweislich nicht genannt es
gab noch nicht mal ein gemeinsames
abendessen und als treffpunkt wurde der
neutral ist mögliche ort gewählt die
schweiz
die ist für heikle begegnungen aller art
ja immer die richtige location
putin hatte im vorfeld erklärt es hätten
sich viele fragen angestaut das kann man
wohl so sagen immer hätten der russische
präsident war ganz entgegen seiner
sonstigen gewohnheiten heute pünktlich
vor ort für begabt das beobachtet
angriffslustig tritt der russische
präsident vor die presse wenn sie
unvoreingenommen berichten würden was
ich sage wüsste ich das sehr zu schätzen
an ihm er putin verbringt den größten
teil der pressekonferenz damit seine
positionen vehement zu verteidigen
dreieinhalb stunden gespräch mit dem
amerikanischen präsidenten haben nichts
daran geändert dass putin torschützen
für die zerrütteten beziehung
verantwortlich macht die usa haben
russland 2007 als feind und rivalen
eingestellt die frage ist also welche
organisation hier sind und war dann in
russland unterstützen durch wenn
russland der erklärte feind ist ich
fürchte es sind nicht die die russen an
stärker machen würden
need to replace kurier.at schon der
handschlag ein etappensieg
danke dass sie dieses treffen initiiert
haben sagt putin der im westen isolierte
präsident wieder auf augenhöhe mit dem
mächtigen mann aus branchen
dafür musste er nur eine glaubhafte
bedrohung darstellen russische truppen
im grenzgebiet zur ukraine zusammen
wir haben heute detailliert über die
nächsten schritte die unsere länder in
der rüstungskontrolle nehmen solche
gesprochen
die schritte die wir gehen müssen um das
risiko eines ungewollten konflikts zu
meinem leben und ich freue mich dass er
zugestimmt hat diesen bilateralen dialog
zu führen dem treffen vorangegangen sind
monate der harschen worte beiden bejaht
die frage ob er putin für einen killer
hatte putin spielt immer wieder auf
alter und gesundheit des amerikaners an
und dann diese bemerkung beiden es aus
2011 die wieder hochkocht er glaube
nicht dass putin eine seele habe diese
dinge haben nichts mit
wir müssen uns nicht in die augen gucken
und eine seele sehen wir müssen die
nationalen interessen unserer länder
verteidigen gelöst
in einem sind sich beide präsidenten
einig voraussetzungen für eine einladung
nach moskau oder washington seien nicht
gegeben
als joe biden pressekonferenz eigentlich
schon vorbei ist haben die journalisten
die wichtigste frage noch nicht
beantwortet bekommen menschenrechte
scheibe an in welchem bereich joe biden
dem russischen präsidenten denn nun
zugeständnisse abgerungen haben will
eine reporterin vom amerikanischen
präsidenten
wenn sie das nicht verstehen werden sie
es nie verstehen sagt joe biden und
reißt ab der amerikanische präsident
unter druck
putin beiden und europa darüber wollen
wir mit dem deutschen aussenminister
sprechen guten abend herr mag hallo frau
stockl als interessierter beobachter wie
haben sie dieses treffen heute
wahrgenommen und schätzen sie das ein
ich bin erstmal froh dass es überhaupt
stattgefunden hat ja nach dem was in den
letzten wochen und monaten so los
gewesen ist das ja keine
selbstverständlichkeit
und dann scheint es nach allem was man
gesehen und gehört hat und was auch wir
von den amerikanern zu hören bekam doch
ein sehr positives gespräch zu sein
gewesen zu sein über viele punkte etwa
über das thema abrüstung aber auch über
viele andere konflikte und ich glaube
den beiden ist klar dass die großen
herausforderungen mit denen wir es heute
zu tun haben da gehört auch der
klimawandel dazu aber da gehört die
globalisierung dazu die digitalisierung
cyber angriffe sind auch ein thema
gewesen
die können nur international gelöst
werden und dafür braucht man russland
und die vereinigten staaten man sich
jetzt noch mal das zustandekommen dieses
treffens anschaut putin lässt truppen an
der ukrainischen grenze aufmarschieren
und daraufhin sagt dann der us-präsident
ja vielleicht sollten aber miteinander
reden ist eigentlich ein punktgewinn für
moskau oder naja es ist ja nicht so
gewesen dass das ohne reaktion geblieben
ist
joe biden hat vorher klipp und klar
gesagt dass er rote linie aufzeigen will
und die situation in der ukraine ist ja
auch ein gesprächsthema gewesen und auch
da hat man sich darauf verständigt dass
die gespräche die deutschland
gleich zusammen mit russland und der
ukraine führen fortgeführt werden sollen
wir sind gerade dabei zu eruieren ob die
außenminister dieser länder sich dem ex
treffen sollen um diese gespräche
fortzuführen und auch da hat dieses
treffen einen guten beitrag gebracht hat
das ja noch mal ehrlich ist dieses ganze
normandie format so nennt man das ja im
hinblick auf den ukraine russland
konflikt eigentlich nicht viel ist einen
großen konflikt geht immer so weiter die
amerikaner sind nicht mit an bord
also da ist jetzt nicht irgendwie eine
lösung zu erwarten in absehbarer zeit in
absehbarer zeit ist auch keine lösung zu
erwarten und ehrlich gesagt hat dass
auch jetzt lange stillstand gegeben
die spannungen zwischen der ukraine und
russland der ständig gewachsen
und deshalb sollten wir uns auch in
diesem format beiden und putin zum
vorbild nehmen und uns zusammensetzen
und darüber reden wie dieser konflikt
zumindest mittel- und langfristig gelöst
wird darin kann man ja auch immer über
vieles natürlich muss in der
außenpolitik auch immer geredet werden
aber es wäre ja auch ganz schön wenn
dann von russischer seite vielleicht
auch mal der andruck käme man würde sich
bewegen oder bestimmte dinge nicht mehr
tun da scheint aber bisher alles reden
und alle warnungen und roten linien und
auch sanktionen eigentlich nichts
gebracht zu haben
naja das ist in vielen bereichen so wir
haben ja auch noch ein anderes thema
etwa mit herrn navalny und auch da hat
sich nichts bewegt aber die tatsache
dass man sich zu einem solchen gespräch
bereit gefunden hat das muss ja auch
einen grund haben und der grund kann nur
sein dass man dazu bereit ist bestimmte
konflikte aufzulösen natürlich will
jeder seine interessen wahren
darüber wird jetzt zu reden sein das ist
ja erst der auftakt gewesen das haben
wir beide auch gesagt es sind
verschiedene formate vereinbart worden
etwa beim thema rüstungskontrolle über
die die jetzt einberufen werden sollen
wo es gespräche geben wird und ich finde
das sind dinge über die man sprechen
musste das ist die voraussetzung dafür
dass es irgendwann auch kompromisse und
lösungen gibt ein klares kontrolle ist
natürlich gerade für europa und für
deutschland die in reichweite stimmt der
raketen sind besonders wichtig aber ist
eine eine menge anderer dinge passierten
da waren die sprachen sie gerade an die
flugzeugentführungen in belarus wo er
kann und habe auch seine finger im spiel
hatte die anschläge in berlin und london
tiergarten mord also man kann gar nicht
aufhören dieses hecking der 1
die einmischung in den armen
panischen wahlkampf ich könnte jetzt
noch eine ewig lange liste aufführen das
einzige was putin doch wirklich weh tun
würde wäre wenn deutschland sich bei
nordstream zwei mal etwas weniger kulant
zeigt mir aber anscheinend sind es die
amerikaner nicht mehr diese auffassung
der führen ja gespräche darüber wie wir
dieses thema das ja auch ein bilateraler
konflikt zwischen deutschland und den
usa ist vernünftig regeln können dabei
geht es wesentlich darum die interessen
der ukraine zu wahren das also durch
diese pipeline nicht die ukraine unter
druck gesetzt werden kann normalerweise
ist das gas nach europa durch die
ukraine geleitet wurden und auch dazu
wird man jetzt gespräche führen wir
sowohl mit den amerikanern und vor allen
dingen haben wir moskau war sehr
deutlich gemacht dass diese pipeline nur
dann mit uns zu ende gebaut wird wenn
der alternative gastransit durch die
ukraine der eine große einnahmequelle
für die ist auch erhalten bleibt und
dazu gibt es jetzt ein vertrag einen
fünfjährigen gas-transit vertrag
zwischen der ukraine und russland und
das ist genau das was wir wollten ja
papier ist geduldig herr putin hat
gerade erst gesagt ob weiterhin
russisches gas durch die ukraine fließt
das hängt von dem wohlverhalten caps ab
das stimmt er hat auch schon viele
andere dinge gesagt wir haben daran
mitgearbeitet das ist ein vertrag gibt
es hier haben wir keinerlei hinweise
dass weder russland noch die ukraine
sich nicht mehr an diesen vertrag
gebunden fühlen ich glaube das ist auch
im interesse beider ukraine will weiter
die einnahmen und die
durchleitungsgebühren für das gas durch
die ukraine
die russen wollen das pipeline nord
stream 2 zu ende gebaut wird und in
betrieb genommen wird und insofern wenn
sich beide an dass das halten was wir
längst vereinbart und auch unterzeichnet
haben
dann glaube ich würde das nicht so wild
wie man vielleicht nach den äußerungen
von vladimir vladimir putin glauben
könnte jetzt sind wir in deutschland im
wahlkampf am see hat das auswärtige amt
oder auch der bnd erkenntnisse dass
russland bereits aktiv damit beschäftigt
ist sich in diesem wahlkampf von der
andere anderen form einzuklinken meinen
wir haben bisher keine konkreten
hinweise die darauf schließen lassen wir
haben aber gesehen dass in der
vergangenheit dass sie in anderen
ländern der fall gewesen ist zum
beispiel in den usa
deshalb sind wir da sehr wachsam und
würden alles was dort geschieht wir
haben uns entsprechend gewappnet um die
dinge früh zu erkennen um sie abstellen
zu können
aber bisher haben wir noch keine
konkreten instrumente gefunden oder
keine konkreten maßnahmen gesehen die
darauf schließen lassen dass wir uns
schon mittendrin befinden in der
einfluss haben wir so wie wir es etwa
bei den amerikanischen
präsidentschaftswahlen hatten
danke für das gespräch so gerne mehr zu
dem treffen heute und den beziehungen
zwischen russland und dem westen finden
sie bei uns online auf zdf heute.de
unter anderem eine analyse unserer
korrespondenten mit welchen strategien
die beiden präsidenten in ihre gespräche
heute in genf hineinging und jetzt
geht's erst mal mit denen nachrichten
weiter und da zunächst mit der
wohnanlage in deutschland heißt ja
darüber haben die gesundheitsminister
von bund und ländern beraten
ein thema die bevorstehende ferien und
reisezeit die minister wollen an der
generellen test licht für flugreisende
aus dem ausland vor abflug festhalten
auch quarantäne regel für bestimmte
gebiete soll es weiter geben
für schulen wollen die länder das
zweimalige testen pro woche
aufrechterhalten
die zahl der korona neuinfektionen ist
weiter rückläufig das robert koch
institut meldet 1455 neuinfektionen
innerhalb eines tages das sind 1799
weniger als letzten metro weitere 137
todesfälle im zusammenhang mit kuwait 19
wurden verzeichnet die sieben tage
incidents liegt bei 13,2 wegen verdacht
auf schweres fehlverhalten unter einigen
deutschen soldaten zieht die bundeswehr
einen zug von rund 30 soldaten aus dem
nato einsatz in litauen ab laut einer
sprecherin des verteidigungsministeriums
stehe der anfangsverdacht auf sexuelle
nötigung sowie rassistische oder
antisemitische beleidigung und
extremistische verhaltensweisen im raum
zehn soldaten sollen an den vorfällen
beteiligt gewesen sein
in litauen sind etwa 600 deutsche
soldaten im einsatz
in berlin ist es vor dem teilweise
besetzten haus regal straße 94 im
stadtteil friedrichshain zu
zusammenstößen mit der polizei gekommen
anhänger der linksradikalen szene hatten
vor dem haus barrikaden errichtet und
angezündet und die polizisten mit
steinen beworfen
rund 60 beamte wurden verletzt
inzwischen wurden die brände gelöscht
morgen ist in dem haus eine brandschutz
prüfung geplant die von der polizei
abgesichert werden soll
wenn man als anti-parteien-partei
auftritt auf establishment und gruppe
eliten schimpft dann ist es natürlich
nicht so schön wenn sich herausstellt
dass man selbst finanzskandale an der
backe hat und im verdacht steht sich von
milliardären auch aus dem ausland
heimlich finanzieren zu lassen
die parteispendenaffäre die heute vor
gericht verhandelt wurde ist nicht die
erste in die afg verwickelt ist
doch jetzt mitten im wahlkampf ist der
zeitpunkt besonders ungünstig zum andern
nicht leute aus der dritten reihe
betrifft sondern die spitzenkandidatin
weit david gebhard und ulrich stoll
berichten deutschland aber normal mit
diesem slogan zieht die afg in den
wahlkampf doch die eigene spendenpraxis
war mitunter wieder normal noch legal
wie heute für die causa weil das
berliner verwaltungsgericht entschied
das parteiengesetz stellt im interesse
der transparenz sehr hohe anforderungen
an die zulässigkeit von parteispenden
und danach ist es unter anderem
unzulässig parteispenden anzunehmen die
von unbekannter herkunft sind
und gegen diesen grundsatz hat die afg
verstoßen 2017 erhielt weidl gestückelte
und verschleierte spenden für ihren
social media wahlkampf auf einen
parteikonto 132000 euro die nicht als
spende gemälde teilweise ausgegeben und
erst nach monaten zurück überwiesen
wurden für die bundestagsverwaltung eine
illegale spende strafe 400.000 euro
weidl wittert eine verschwörung eine
junge oppositionspartei wird für spenden
die in voller höhe zurückgezahlt wurden
und von denen kein vorteil erwachsen ist
mit der maximalen strafe belegt das
ganze zu beginn eines bundestagswahl
ganz komplett anders sehen das afd
parteifreunde die anders als weil heute
vor ort sind ich kann das urteil nachdem
teilnehmern der veranstaltung hier und
heute verstehen es war auch so
eigentlich nach kurzer zeit im lauf
verlauf der verhandlung so absehbar auch
für einen laien wandels geldgeber sollte
er auch in der schweiz residierende
media der henning conley sein
nach recherchen von zdf und korrektiv
soll dieser ebenfalls mit weiteren
social media aktivitäten die afg
unterstützt haben das behauptet auch die
frühere fdp chefin frauke petry
ich habe dem bundestagspräsidenten
angezeigt das sind meiner kenntnis ich
habe neun illegale spendengelder von
herrn konnte in die partei hinein
gelenkt und an offiziellen strukturen
vorbei eingesetzt hat leuten möchte sich
dazu nicht äußern weitere strafzahlungen
für die partei stehen im raum
im fall weil könnte die afg in berufung
gehen der ruf nach möglichen
konsequenzen kommt schon heute sollte
wirklich hier natürlich dann am ende
dann der vorwurf im raum bleiben denke
ich dass frau weiter selbstbewusst genug
ist und dann auch notwendige
konsequenzen zu ziehen wären also ich
denke dass dann eine erneute kandidatur
um den fraktionsvorsitz nicht in
betracht kommen darf die afg startet mit
einer weiter spielenden spendenaffäre
und einer belasteten spitzenkandidatin
in den wahlkampf eine partei mit streit
und offenen rechnungen
streit und offene rechnungen gibt es
auch auf der anderen seite des
politischen spektrums dass sich die
verschiedenen lager aber der partei die
linke mit harten bandagen bekämpfen ist
nicht neu allerdings verband die partei
mit ihrer neuen führung die hoffnung
dass sich wenigstens im wahlkampf alle
etwas mehr am riemen reißen und manche
gräben auch zugeschüttet werden
das scheint jedoch nicht so recht zu
klappen mittendrin in der kampfzone
und auch das ist nicht neu das ehepaar
lafontaine wagenknecht oskar lafontaine
hat jetzt im saarland sogar dazu
aufgerufen die linke nicht zu wählen
ein fraktionschef der zum boykott seiner
eigenen partei aufruf wo gibt's denn
sowas an der saar
was dahinter steckt berichtet susanne
freitag beim einstigen polit traumpaar
der linken ist der beziehungsstatus
kompliziert geworden wenn es um das
verhältnis zu ihrer partei geht sahra
wagenknecht bekommt gegenwind in nrw
einige verlangen ihren parteiausschluss
sie schade der linken heißt es und ihr
ehemann oskar lafontaine rief im
saarland dazu auf die eigene partei
nicht zu wählen
grund ihr spitzenmann letzte woche in
neuenkirchen hatten die parteimitglieder
entschieden
99 stimmen der parteivorsitzende thomas
lutze ist die nummer eins der
saarländischen landesliste er und oskar
lafontaine bekriegen sich das zerreißt
die partei seit jahren gegen nutzer
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft vorwurf
er soll stimmen gekauft haben angezeigt
wurde er aus den reihen der fraktion dem
lafontaine lager nun fordert der
landesvorstand oskar lafontaine zum
parteiaustritt auf öffentlich muss man
nicht mehr möglich sind deckel drauf zu
halten es war jetzt einfach einen punkt
erreicht wo viele mitglieder sowohl
funktionsträger mandatsträger aus den
kommunen gesagt haben wir muss jetzt mal
ein zeichen gesetzt werden und ein
landesvorstand hat letztendlich auch die
verantwortung dazu mal klare signale zu
senden
das muss nun auch die bundespartei aber
welche die linke perfekt die
parteispitze lehnt ausschlüsse der
beiden ab dennoch übt sie kritik an
wagenknecht und auch an lafontaine mit
ihm will man jetzt klärende gespräche
führen aber er hat auch unterstützer in
berlin
die jetzt den ausschluss von oskar
lafontaine oder ähnliches ins spiel
bringen da kann ich nur sagen die sollen
sie mal darüber nachdenken ob die partei
überhaupt gebe und seine funktion hätten
wenn oskar lafontaine nicht gewesen wäre
der zank um die zugpferde belastet die
partei auch hier im thüringischen
langensalza sahra wagenknecht war das
hat mich auch bisschen erschüttern so
weil sie hat ja auch viele fans und es
wird zum teil schaden nehmen einst
gehörte oskar lafontaine zu den
gründervätern der linken
er hat die partei erfolgreich bin im
saarland wurde er zum garanten für
zweistellige wahlergebnisse in einem
west bundesland aber braucht die partei
ist die frage ob beide der genannten
namen lafontaine wagen wird vielleicht
für eine alte linke steht die nicht mehr
wirklich im zentrum stehen sollte aus
sicht der bundes linke und dieser kampf
diese auseinandersetzung wird
wahrscheinlich am wochenende eine große
rolle spielen denn am wochenende ist der
parteitag auf dem die linke nicht nur
ein programm sondern auch sich selbst
finden muss und jetzt nochmal eins erst
mal mit einem blick auf die deutsche
wirtschaft das ifo institut erwartet in
seiner neuen konjunkturprognose ein
wirtschaftswachstum von 3,3 prozent in
deutschland das ist etwas weniger als
noch im märz angenommen wurde war die
hölle
was bremst das liegt an lieferengpässen
zahlreichen firmen fehlt es schlicht und
ergreifen dann wichtigen materialien
weil zulieferer mit dem nachschub nicht
mehr hinterherkommen und das bremst
inzwischen ganze branchen aus und mit
ihnen den aufschwung in deutschland vor
allem vorprodukte fehlen baumaterialien
oder holz aber eben auch chips für die
autoindustrie sind mangelware
so sehr dass vw und daimler mit
kurzarbeit darauf reagieren
betroffen sind vor allem beschäftigte in
der fertigung im mercedes-werk in bremen
wurde für einen großteil der
beschäftigten kurzarbeit beantragt mehr
als 12.000 mitarbeiter sind dort
beschäftigt dafür könnte es laut ifo
institut im kommenden jahr mit der
konjunktur wesentlich kräftiger
aufwärtsgehen als ursprünglich gedacht
auch soll sich die lage am arbeitsmarkt
weiter entspannen allerdings müssen sich
unternehmen und bürger laut ifo
wenigstens vorübergehend auf höhere
preise einstellen
an der börse in frankfurt hielten
anleger die füße still der dax beendet
den tag kaum verändert denn hier wartete
man auf die ergebnisse der sitzung der
amerikanischen notenbank die kamen am
abend heraus und enthielten auch eine
überraschung die fed lässt die zinsen
zwar aktuell wo sie sind signalisiert
aber für das jahr 20 23 eine erste
anhebung und das früher als erwartet sie
rechnet mit mehr wachstum aber eben auch
dort mit mehr inflation weil real
vielen dank der präsident des deutschen
olympischen sportbundes alfons hörmann
zieht die konsequenzen aus der
führungskrise und wird bei den nun für
dezember angesetzt neuwahlen nicht
erneut antreten
auslöser der krise war ein anonymes
schreiben mit kritik am führungsstil
die ethik-kommission empfahl dann
vorgezogene neuwahlen
zwei ergebnisse von der
fußball-europameisterschaft schon heute
in der gruppe b hatte russland 1 0 0
gegen finnland gewonnen und in der
gruppe a in wales als sieger vom platz
im spiel gegen die türkei mit 2 zu 0
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
1 22 25 28 37 44 superzahl 7 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
geschichtsfälschung und relativierung
ist das eine sie geschickt bewusst
etwa wenn rechtsradikale den holocaust
klein und den ruhm der deutschen
wehrmacht groß reden
aber es kommt noch ein anderes problem
herr zu geschichtsvergessenheit die umso
leichter fällt
je weniger zeitzeugen es noch gibt die
berichten über das dunkelste kapitel der
deutschen geschichte
nichts ist so eindrücklich wie
persönliche schicksale und wenn die
menschen selbst nicht mehr erzählen
können dann ist ja umso wichtiger was
sie an gesagte und geschriebene und
hinterlassen
in berlin wurde heute eine besonders
umfängliche sammlung dem
bundespräsidenten übergeben
historiker haben in jahrelanger arbeit
zigtausende dokumente zusammengestellt
darunter tagebucheinträge und briefe aus
denen bundespräsident steinmeier bei
seiner rede zitierte sonne wald
berichtet im 2 november 1942 werfen
salomon und hanna gottlieb eheleute aus
den niederlanden eine karte aus dem
demonstrationszug schreiben an ihre
tochter und ihren schwiegersohn liebe
kinder
wir sind auf dem weg nach birkenau
glauben wir auf jeden fall sind wir auf
dem weg irgendwohin verliert nicht den
mut eurem utter und euer vater
diese karte ist eines von mehr als 5000
zeugnissen zum holocaust in fast zwei
jahrzehnten von historikern
zusammengetragen
eine 16 wendige quellensammlung über die
verfolgung und ermordung der
europäischen juden durch die nazis
erstmalig werden hier dokumente von
tätern opfern und zuschauern
veröffentlicht in deutschland ist es ja
lange zeit so gewesen dass die
holocaustforschung sich auf die
dokumente der täter gestützt hat also
wenn man laut der täter dokumente am
stück liest dann übernimmt man ob man
will oder nicht
man denkt sich rein in die optik der
täter während wenn was wir immer machen
wir wechseln das durchaus ab diese
perspektive sehen also ganz
unterschiedliche dokumente nebeneinander
stehen die 16 bände skizzieren die
entrechtung unterdrückung schikane
ghettoisierung deportation und ließ sich
den mord und die vernichtung der juden
nicht nur in deutschland sondern auch in
anderen
europäischen ländern wie rumänien
norwegen und griechenland
dass man sie versteht dass das nicht
eine genozid auf einem platz war sondern
dass das eine ein welt problem ist und
war anita lasker wallfisch hat als
cellist indes lager kurs das kz
auschwitz und bergen-belsen überlebt
über ihre erinnerungen an die shoah hat
sie oft berichtet auch für die vom
bayerischen rundfunk produzierte höhere
edition die quellen sprechen
mehr als 70 zeugen lesen hier dokumente
aus der 16 bändigen holocaust edition
und erzählen ihre eigene geschichte
ernst grube berichtet wie er und seine
geschwister als halbjuden und
kommunisten in münchen verfolgt und
schließlich im mai 1945 aus dem kz
theresienstadt befreit wurden die
geschwister meiner mutter und männer
wurden in polen h spitze gebracht und
dort umgebracht aber neben fall war das
schon sehr persönlich motiviert hier
mehr zu erfahren und mitzuwirken
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
hat heute in berlin eine gesamtausgabe
erhalten
symbolisch für die öffentlichkeit die
die umfassende dokumentation nutzen soll
an universitäten und schulen lassen sie
uns die erinnerung an die schoah
gemeinsam wach halten lassen sie uns
antisemitischen hass entgegentreten ganz
gleich in welcher form er sich äußert
und lassen sie uns eintreten für die
demokratie und die würde jedes und jeder
einzelnen die 16 wände sind bereits
digitalisiert und werden nun ins
englische übersetzt
so sollen noch mehr menschen weltweit
einblick bekommen in diese einzigartige
dokumentensammlung über die shoah
das war es von uns im heute journal im
auslandsjournal geht es gleich weiter
unter anderem mit der reportage aus
sankt petersburg auch einer der
austragungsorte der europameisterschaft
deren schatten der kreml für eine
stillgelegte opposition sorgt oder 0 30
gibt es dann unser heute schnorr update
mit nah sein möchte mir und wir melden
uns morgen der halbzeitpause auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schöner und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter schauen wir zurück auf den
frühling in diesem jahr unter war in
mitteleuropa ziemlich kalt der letzte
deutlich kältere frühling 2013
dazwischen die ganzen jahre einfach
immer zu warm wie heute wir sehen hier
einen blauen fleck über mitteleuropa
ansonsten war es zum beispiel deutlich
wärmer richtung sibirien global war es
wieder zu warm denn die erhitzung setzt
sich weiter fort trotz lokaler kälte
hier sehen wir es noch mal denn die
kälte die kam meist aus dem norden mehr
regional die wetterlage hatte sich
regelrecht festgefressen nun bekommen
wir die regionale südlage und zu sehen
hier die hitze kommt aus nordafrika zu
uns über mehrere tage und dieses tief
hier wird hängenbleiben und
dementsprechend dauert das auch einige
zeit bis die hitze wieder ausgeräumt
wird
in der nacht wird das erste mal auf
klaren kaum wolken unterwegs und die
temperaturen sinken auf 21 grad im
westen deutschlands
das ist eine tropische nacht alles was
über 20 grad liegt wird so definiert zum
beispiel dann auch richtung rhein main
12 bis 13 grad deutlich angenehmer im
südosten deutschlands morgen im
tagesverlauf einzelne gewitter im westen
können schon unwetterartig sein
ansonsten viel sonnenschein bei bis zu
36 grad aber schauen sie verbreitet
liegen die werte über der 30 grad marke
am kühlsten mit 26 grad an der ostsee ja
und der höhepunkt am freitag mit 37 grad
mit unwetter am samstag setzt sich das
fort hauptsächlich dann im osten die
unwetter sonntag könnte es dann zu noch
heftigeren gewittern kommen damit ein
schöner ort